[Music]
hi
hi everybody thank you so much for
joining us on only day two of our show
i love twos i'm my birthday is february
22nd so i'm 2 22.
that's right oh gosh i'm so happy to be
here
thank you for joining us we're always
looking for ways to explore
every angle of life on this show and
serve it up sunny side up
that doesn't make sense but it does and
the bright side of today's show
herself miss hello sunshine bruce
witherspoon is on the show
hi virtual friends hey by the way does
anyone have a favorite reese witherspoon
movie
yes cindy yes
[Music]
you love legally blonde yes my favorite
of all time
is that your daughter yes
hi how are you cute
thank you for sharing mine is actually
election
um with reese witherspoon hashtag tracy
flick
now let's look at the bright side of the
news
with drew's news
[Applause]
excuse me sir ma'am guy
tell me your story
ma'am i asked you a question
this is
is true news it's drew's news
ah every day
our mission at drew's news is to bring
the good
stories happening in the world to all of
you
again consider me your human scrapbook
for fun stories now first up
check this out i got to go to the empire
state building and flip the switch
there it goes and then the whole
building
turned yellow all night long in honor of
our
signature color for the show look at her
it's a girl
and look they gave me this beautiful
lucite statue i'll keep it forever
thank you so much again now let's look
and see what made the papers
and surprise it's taco news day
look at that animation i love it taco
plus
news hashtag taco newsday i'm so happily
jealous from this next story
it's from oh magazine gail king love her
revealed that when she was quarantining
at oprah's house
that they do taco tuesday i mean
oh my god the things we would all do to
be invited to that taco tuesday
but for now we can check it out in the
october issue of o magazine
yeah okay i am a huge
fan of letter writing it's a really big
deal in my world
and so this next story really does it
for me
huffpost has a story about the ongoing
resurgence
of real snail mail pen pals
i'm talking paper stamps
envelopes the usps
[Applause]
show of hands and our virtual friends
who love
snail mail audience i mean crew
i love it samesies letter writing is
very personal for me um i wrote
postcards to my daughters all the time
when they're at camp they get each one
a day with a joke on it and look okay
this will drive the point home
my family has stamps yeah that's the
barry mars
hi guys listen
the power of a letter cannot be
underestimated
and we're even going to have an upcoming
segment here
called dear drew where you can send us a
letter
with your photos a silly story a joke a
bill
anything and i'll read it on the show
look we made postcards
that's how serious i am also if you want
to get in this pen cal
pen pal game two check out the worldwide
snail mail pen pals look at these ladies
look at all the good they're doing
these seniors are so happy to get these
letters
and i found one for kids and we're
recommending
the secret society of letter writers
it's a free club that encourages a kid
to get into the pen pal game and receive
letters so both resources are
on our website go check it out
snail mail all right
get ready for this next transition
because this one is about the latest and
innovative beauty trends all right
allure magazine by the way hi michelle
lee i love you
okay so we all know about face masks
right uh
what about face mask for your butt
uh yeah apparently this is a thing i
mean
okay right they exfoliate and
i don't know their kesha is even excited
about it and she has a video
uh to show her derriere skin care
hashtag dairy or skincare
take a look a big fan of doing that mask
and it comes with a little
butt thing it's shaped like a butt i
love fuzz
okay you know i saw this story and i was
like come on
i'm a beauty junkie and i know all
things and this was even news to me
and i admit at first i was like this is
just kooka doodle
and then i was like you know what though
i'm actually going home tonight to try
this so if anyone wants to try it with
me i'm going to talk about it
and report back tomorrow
[Music]